elle est loin du grand garcia où la
banquise amène les phoques
mais elle se débat
c'est seulement en se tenant hors de
l'eau que je vois dans quel état elle est elle est
fatiguée émaciée et doit trouver à manger
rapidement
nos réserves de graisse ne la protègent plus guère
du froid
et de mon propre point de vue solitaire,
toute l'horreur et la raison de sa
situation difficile deviennent claires d'abord, elle
a commencé l'été trop mince et contrairement à
son frère n'a pas pu chasser
efficacement, puis la glace a
complètement disparu cette année même si nous sommes
au cœur de la  Arctic bien que certains
ours soient clairement plus égaux que d'autres,
je suis convaincu qu'elle aurait
mieux résisté dans des conditions normales, elle doit
tenir encore un mois
reflètent l'avenir de
toute l'espèce que les ours
polaires connaissent depuis si longtemps, maîtres de la
glace, s'adaptent d'une manière ou d'une autre aux forces du
réchauffement climatique qui modifient leur
environnement plus rapidement que quiconque aurait pu
l'imaginer
à la vitesse à laquelle l'Arctique
fond en partie à cause d'une trop grande présence humaine
pollution les ours polaires ne peuvent pas se permettre d'
attendre la réponse
[Musique]